the debate continues over health  insurance for teachers it was another  late school board meeting last night  where members heard a presentation from  the ccea on this situation the education  association laid out an inconsistent  history with tht health many teachers  are worried because doctors are dropping  their coverage bills are being sent to  collection agencies  i would have loved to teach for another  five to ten years but i was tired of  seeing other educators get ill or die  too young from stress-induced illnesses  i had to make a change to be able to  enjoy my life  last night's meeting only was a  presentation no action has been taken in  a statement released late last night  ccsd said ccea failed to adequately  explain the problem but also said  teachers deserve an effective  functioning health care plan